I'm Elizabeth Blackburn and the
professor at the University of
California San Francisco
I'm actually the Morrisville Stein
professor of physiology and biology in
the department of biophysics and
biochemistry how about that and or maybe
it's biochemistry and biophysics
anyway I grew up in Tasmania and I had a
lot of opportunity to be outdoors and I
loved animals and my mom told me that I
would play with poisons jellyfish and in
Australia there are ants that sting you
really badly and I would pick them up
and cradle them in my hand and talk to
them so I just thought all living things
were wonderful when we think of life we
tend to think of what's what's a little
bit more identifiably like a senior we
think of us of course we think of you
know mammals pets and you know furry
things and then we you know think about
fish and we think about plants and
things and yet there's an enormous
universe of life which we don't happen
to see with the naked eye but microscope
to make you know abundantly clear
so I happen to be working with a very
tiny single-celled organism and it
actually lives in pond scum and it's
called tetrahymena very charming and it
swims around a little corkscrew kind of
tracks and has seven sexes by the way
exciting little life under the pond in
the surface so the point is that it has
a lot of very tiny chromosomes and I
decided to look at what's at the ends of
chromosomes because nobody knew what
actually was there so what's at the very
end of the chromosome is given the name
the telomere and just mean Atilla means
end date from the Greek and Mir body and
we discovered an enzyme that was
completely new at the time that adds
extra DNA elongates those ends so that
solves a problem how the chromosomes
replicate and yet not lose DNA from
their ends well if you have something
that just keeps adding backs and extra
so that was really you know huge fun to
find this and we found this in
tetrahymena some people like to you know
explore outer space and you know that's
an unknown world and yet there are these
little tiny on
worlds which was this very simple what's
at the end of chromosomes
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the baobab fruit
contains four times the potassium of
banana three times the vitamin C of an
orange and twice the calcium of spinach
but the Bale Bob is an orphan science
has paid little attention to this tree
until now the African orphan crops
consortium is harnessing the power of
genetics for orphan crops the bail Bob
tree is the first of 101 plants to have
its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture
you